congratulations
by being here listening a life a member
of a growing species you are one of
history's greatest winners the
culmination of a success story for
billion years in the making
you are life's one percent the losers
the 99% of species who have ever lived
our debt killed by fire flood asteroids
predation starvation ice heat and the
cold math of natural selection your
ancestors back to the earliest fishes
overcame all these challenges you are
here because of golden opportunities
made possible by mass extinction
it's true the same is true of your
co-winners and relatives the 34,000
kinds of fishes how did we all get so
lucky will we continue to win I am a
fish paleo biologists who use this big
data the fossil record to study how some
species win and others lose the living
can't tell us they know nothing but
winning so we must speak with the dead
how do we make that fish's talk museums
contain multitudes of beautiful fish
fossils but their real beauty emerges
when combined with the larger number of
ugly broken fossils and reduced to ones
and zeroes I control a 500 million year
database for evolutionary patterns for
example fish forms can be captured by
coordinates and transform to reveal
major pathways of change and trends
through time here is the story of the
winners and losers of just one pivotal
that I discovered using fossil data
let's travel back 360 million years six
times as long ago as the last dinosaur
to the Devonian period a strange world
armored predators with razor edge jaws
dominated alongside huge fishes with arm
bones in their fins crab like fishes
scuttled across the seafloor the few
Wraith and relatives of salmon and tuna
cowered at the bottom of the food chain
the few early sharks lived offshore in
fear your few four-legged ancestors the
tetrapods struggled in tropical River
Plains ecosystems were crowded there was
no escape no opportunity in sight then
the world ended
no it is a good thing 96% of all fish
species died during the Hagen Berg event
359 million years ago an interval of
fire and ice a crowded world was
disrupted and swept away now you might
think that's the end of the story
the mighty fell the meek inherited the
earth and here we are but winning is not
that simple the handful of survivors
came from many groups all greatly
outnumbered by their own dead they
ranged from top predator to bottom
feeder big to small marine to freshwater
the extinction was a filter it merely
leveled the playing field
what really counted was what survivors
did over the next several million years
in that devastated world
the former Overlord should have had an
advantage they became even larger
storing energy investing in their young
spreading across the globe feasting on
fishes keeping what had always worked
and biding their time yet they merely
persisted for a while it's a climbing
without innovating becoming living
fossils they were too stuck in their
weights and are now largely forgotten a
few of the long-suffering ravens sharks
and poor legged tetrapods what the
opposite direction they became smaller
living fast dying young eating little
and reproducing rapidly they tried new
foods different homes strange heads and
weird bodies and they found opportunity
proliferated and won the future for
their 60,000 living species including
you that's why they look familiar you
know their names winning is not about
random events or an arms race rather
survivors went down alternative
evolutionary pathways some found
incredible success while others became
dead fish walkie
a real scientific term I am now
investigating how these pathways to
victory and defeat repeat across time my
lab has already compiled thousands upon
thousands of dead fishes but many more
remain however it is already clear that
your ancestors survival through mass
extinction and their responses in the
aftermath made you who you are today
what does this tell us for the future as
long as the handful of species survive
life will recover the versatile and the
lucky will not just replace what was
lost but win in new forms it just might
take several million years thank you
[Applause]